this past weekend okay we got the audio
going cutting this on just took my Afrin
so
hopefully that's gonna help me breathe
[Music]
happy to be here
a little frustrating
[Music]
and trying to quit smoking
thank you for joining me man and I
haven't been a smoker but I just kind of
started you know really just kind of
farting around with the habit and and
cigarettes are crazy I don't know what
they put in cigarettes cocaine maybe but
they are an enticing little treat you
know and you start thinking you they
become the first thing you think of
sometimes cigarettes you know they
become the first thing that you think of
if you have in a moment of difficulty or
a moment of triumph instead of thinking
man how do I solve this how do I feel
about this how do I do anything instead
you have a cigarette
you know you just smoke that feeling out
of your brain and out of your
bloodstream with that uh cigarette smoke
you know and this is an age-old
tradition and I don't think it's bad
long term if you can use it in severe
moderation the problem is doing that
that's the hard thing so I've done great
with it over the years flared up
probably in the past year the past few
months have been great and then now it's
really I've fallen just in the past
three or four days just fell back down
that stairs you know that carcinogen
staircase you know when you just just
banging your head and on each stair as
you bounce down you know you emphysema
asthma the Black Lung pop you know
getting your toes cut off and the next
thing you know you're lying at the
bottom of the staircase
you know you breathing through one of
those you know those gangster-ass throat
holes you know I mean some of those
throat holes get big you know I've seen
somebody had I mean I'm surprised a
couple Ninja Turtles didn't pop out of
it you know this fella had a real he had
a real uh he had a real you know we're
real little almost like a big third
nostril you know he could take a hit off
the whole world through his neck but
it's not healthy you know when you have
that that kind of stuff isn't healthy
but but
so today I've gone all day I've had some
cravings you know I mean if you'd have
told me there was a hit and nicotine in
my bloodstream I would have I would have
dressed up like a vampire and damn bit
myself okay that's why was that
but welcome guys I appreciate you being
here with me this morning I really do
appreciate your time this is Monday
August 21st 2017 and as far as we know
and for most of us this will be the only
Monday August 21st 2017 that we ever
have you know unless there are some time
travelers out there you know I like to
start thinking about time travel and I'm
gonna look into it I'm gonna do some
Google research and then some real
research you know and just talk to
friends and see maybe what they think
about time travel or their time
travelers here how does that work what's
going on you know what do they eat what
do they do what do they do in their
spare time you know a lot of times you
see these Tom travelling shows and
people travel a time they travel through
time with a poignant purpose you know
they got something on their mind you
know they got a little bit of beef they
got a you know that they got a that they
have to you know grill but in a
different time period so you got them
straight up people traveling just trying
to you know cure cure meats you know and
buy meats I mean different issues that
are going on you know maybe they got a
travel back 100 years to because they
they're helping with prohibition or they
got to travel back 70 years because
they're helping you know somebody took a
gunshot wound and they got it step in
the way of it or something you know
there's always a specific meat that
they're heading back to grill if you
will that's all metaphorical the type of
thing cold there's a specific reason
that they're traveling back in time
right well I wonder what do time
travellers do when they're not being
specific you know what are they doing
they're just kind of milling around do
they you know you know is it hard if you
travel back in time because you don't
have the the customs and the probably
the dope future [ __ ] the DFS that they
have down the road I don't know but
anyhow you might be able to time travel
today because it's eclipse day people
have been talking about it right it is a
solar eclipse and one of the one of the
things that's apparently amazing about
this one is that it's the this one is
the the
the the best one since 1918 that you can
see here in the United States it's
basically diagonal across the United
States from Portland down I want to say
to Florida but that's you know just me
taking the easiest way out of of this
question or out of this thought but its
diagonal across the US there's a lot of
people apparently have descended upon
Portland to the CCC stuff go dark you
know and it's interesting man since 1918
you know and my father actually so some
of you guys know my father was born in
1910 so my father was 8 years old and I
don't know if he saw the Eclipse or not
if it was as big of a thing to them but
it's just interesting to think sometimes
like what your parents were doing when
they were children you know I always put
my parents or I always put adults
especially as you grow up on this odd
pedestal in this special place I mean
surely they have more knowledge so you
you you most of the time you'll accept
that but then you also put them in this
other sort of realm of humanity and of
experience but then as you get older it
it's it's interesting to try and think
back what they were like as children you
know I'm gonna think about my father in
1918 you know maybe standing out there
looking at the Eclipse down in Nicaragua
I don't know if they got it you know I
don't think he came to America actually
till he was 12 years old but I do
remember my dad telling me one time that
two of his buddies are two children in
his neighborhood got into a gunfight
children okay children got into a
gunfight and they went and and it wasn't
like gangbangers type of stuff this was
some kid said I'm going to get my gun
some kids that I'm going to get my
daddy's gun and then went both went got
guns six shooters then they came outside
and they both shot shot at each other
six times each 12 times and didn't hit
each other dude is that I mean that's
when you think about it that is
remarkable that two kids somewhere
around the age of 10 or 11 years old or
12 years old
went and got six shooters shot him off
at each other and didn't hit each other
man I mean that's truly beautiful when
you think about it
you know I mean but those were different
times man that's maybe when you settle
things like that
you know but it's the longest visible
eclipse in America since 1918 you know
wonderful animals and plants are they
concerned like when the Sun goes out you
know or dogs gonna well cats give a [ __ ]
you know will ferns kind of start
creeping on people or you know get Nyree
you know I'm just kind of wondering what
else the rest of nature is doing you
know cuz we have 50,000 people fly until
we're gonna go witness this you know I
think I'm fine witnessing witnessing it
from here it'll it'll hit us at 10:28
a.m. Pacific Standard Time so that's you
know noon 28 a.m. noon 28 p.m. Central
Standard Time so if you want to get out
there and check it out man but yeah I
think about that sometimes what our
parents were like what they did when
they were young cuz they just did
regular dumb kid [ __ ] like we did you
know like they weren't they weren't our
parents back then they were just
children when they were young so they
were just doing dumb [ __ ] you know and
my father probably lived in a time I'm
thinking you know went over the summer
or whatever your buddy just died you
know and even a lot of times like the
30s and stuff the Dust Bowl 20 I mean
people just died you're like I mean
people only live to maybe what 40 years
old 41 people died all the time you know
you'd be walking to church or something
somebody gets bit by a snake dies dude
before brunch I mean that's crazy
you know it's crazy to think that how
people just died all the time fever
snakes you know spiders attack animals
you know strangling strangling dude come
on you even imagine the amount of
strangling that that was going on back
then you know I mean you could leave for
a school year come back half your
classes missing you know two people died
of tetanus one kid bitten by wolf you
know where's Lawrence I
No you know he went to get some water
nobody ever saw him again
you know do you want some of his old
pants I don't know let's play marbles
before we probably die you know let's
get in let's get a game of marbles in
before the Lord comes and gets us you
know that's what I'm thinking is
probably said to be a wild universe back
then you know but the Eclipse is here
man it's a great time probably to steal
some [ __ ] if you think about stealing
some [ __ ] great I'm gonna show somebody
your dick or something you know if
you're under that kind of stuff if
you're into the dark arts but it's a
great time to kind of act out I think
and I think it's nice also because we've
been needing something in America that
especially in America maybe in the world
that just shows us that Mother Nature is
the boss you know we're kind of hooked
on them on us being the boss we control
it all
you know we're one fancy tidal wave from
everybody you know being out on the
street you know you know shank and each
other out for uh four cans of of
albacore fish you know where we are we
are we are one long you know thunderous
earthquake away from people you know
setting traps in the park to try and get
a pair of new shorts you know I mean
that's where we're at you know people
don't realize that I think we've gotten
so caught up in ourselves we're almost
bored in America you know in the way
that we don't we starting to forget
there were humans in a way what if that
makes sense anybody we're starting to
forget there were humans you know like
being human doesn't seem as important as
like being right or being wrong or being
selfish those things seem to have taken
up most importance but I don't know man
it's just wild dude so I'm glad that
mother nature's coming just do a little
bit of aerial work you know a little bit
of cert to Seoul are you know get out
there and show her nuts off because you
know mother nature's transgender don't
you know don't you know that you know
mother nature's transgender dude I mean
you know she's getting out there with
them solar balls you know I'm gonna make
them
work make them do a little bit of sky
work so I'm excited to see that because
we need something we need something just
to show us a you know that that that we
as people are more important we need
have some empathy there's not a lot of
empathy these days everybody wants to be
right you know why do we have to be
right that's so crazy you know I can
understand us wanting to be right but
having to be right is just a kind of a
reach but anyhow what else is going on
man yeah I was just thinking about that
but you know what it was like when my
father was young he told me kids were
real starving out in Nicaragua and they
would eat dirt he said they had children
I would eat dirt in this village where
his family was doing some missionary
work over there or where they were doing
some church work and and he that he'd
see children eating dirt you know making
but they would mold the dirt into food
and they need it and that's pretty it's
interesting you know it's kind of ball
that's fun that's pretty gangster you
know it's like yeah anybody could just
eat dirt dude but what about this dirt
Brule I'm about to have I respect people
like that people that have an
imagination even in the toughest of
times yeah I hate to say that but I mean
maybe that's wild but I feel like we
need something in mother nature or in
the world and I don't want to you know
I've thought about a war even to be
honest you know I mean I don't want to
see loss of life and that's where they
go we need something that helps us all
realize that we are on the same page you
know that we are humans here together I
mean it's crazy to think that we are
this speck in the middle of nowhere and
we're fighting I mean is Error here are
we you know what's wrong with us you
know that we're spec in the middle of
nowhere we could be doing anything and
we're fighting man and we're not all
fighting but these days in America is a
lot of there's a lot of boiling a lot of
boiling going on a lot of people boiling
a lot of people you know thinking
feeling and I'll say one thing it's
interesting man it's great almost you
know I like the fact that even
it's frustrating when I wake up or when
I hear so I feel I have a prime I I care
I have a point of view because for a
long time my generation I'm 37 years I'm
an adult male and from my generation
there was a 20 year span there were four
there was no he got up he didn't really
care everybody just kind of went on with
Everett there was no sides there was no
purpose there was no vigor he almost
didn't even need your nutsack yeah I
remember at the time I always remember
thinking I don't even you know I wish my
nuts were detachable I'm leaving here at
the house I'd hang them by that one
winter hat that I wear once a year you
know where that whistle everybody has a
frickin whistle on there dang coat rack
what are you doing with a stupid whistle
that creeps me out when I go to your
place and you got us if you got a hat
rack I'll look at it I love I will
always been a kind of an aficionado of
hat racks and see racks coat racks and I
will if you got a whistle hang in there
do but you're not really you're not a
referee or something shut it down shut
it down baby bear you know but I'm
excited you know like I am hopeful
because now people are feeling this
purpose people are gonna people want to
say something people want to feel
something you know I get up out of bed
and I feel might be anger but at least
I'm feeling at least I'm being reminded
that I'm alive you know because we're
quickly in other ways turning into
zombies and I feel like maybe that doubt
you know I you know I don't want it to
be a wild love a natural disaster of
some crazy story it might sound you know
it sounds a little crazy saying it but
if not do we just taper off into
oblivion with losing our feelings and
becoming you know just we're gonna be
the worst robots will be eliminated and
real robots will take over you know I
remember talking to my niece the other
day I'm talking about imagination I say
use your imagination and she goes I
don't think I have that on my phone
I see your imagination it's it's an app
that's in your head you know but now
it's like man so I just would love to be
because if you're in the trenches if
there's something on the line if there's
a war there's a natural disaster
if the aliens coming you know
then we're then you're gonna have to
team up with so it's not gonna matter
you know because then we're all gonna be
on the same side we're gonna realize
that we're all humans we're not just
weird I was hiding behind Twitter
threatening each other in fighting and I
used Twitter but GD man let's shut it
down that thing is ruining humanity it's
ruining it it's just fury I open
Instagram I'm kind of okay on Instagram
I feel you know it's fun you can see
things funny stuff
Twitter draw ruins it ruins doesn't it
it's pretty interesting how different
apps have almost become where we go to
express certain feelings you know but
yeah my nice thought imagination was an
app I don't have I don't think I have
that on this phone you know using her
mother's phone my sister Oh what else
Jerry Lewis died
rest in peace mr. Lewis if you're not
familiar with Jerry Lewis which a lot of
people aren't a lot of younger people
are not familiar with Jerry Lewis you
know and that's okay
you know he was older I mean the guy was
in his 90s I think he's I'm gonna say 91
years old and that's old man when you're
91 I mean you you know you probably have
a lot of you'll take your shirt off and
I bet there's kind of a dust or
something in it you know that's part of
you but visible always on you you know
whatever hey like you have no clue CEO
people with their ears a lot of times
just overgrown ears you know like a
family used to live in their ears and
then their ears became haunted and now
they're not taking care of the yard
anymore because the family moved out you
know I mean Oh be sometime you see old
people have hair I remember this one
dude had a hair coming right off his
nose
man and it was probably four inches long
I mean it was almost like a fishing like
a cane pole like it was just was trying
to catch fish out of his mouth and this
man had the longest nose hair I'd ever
singing you know in part of me often
wonders if at night you know for him
after he brushed his teeth he might pull
that fine sucker down and floss his
little beautiful ah his beautiful little
chess pieces in his mouth you know floss
those beautiful enamel pawns he's got
but but yeah when you get older
sometimes you don't know what's going on
you know I had a they had a man in our
neighborhood he he had a big hump on his
back
you know this man named big Dan but they
called him Obi Dan because of the hump
you know a real pale it kept my tat a
son and then his cousin would walk
around usually and he was cousins
probably maybe 20 years younger but his
cousin would kind of pull they didn't
have an umbrella but he put like a tarp
over him if he had to be outside you
know and uh
Mobe Dan that's just what the kids kind
of joked and called him but he had this
big old hump and it just kept growing
and it got almost higher than his head
dude I mean if a bunch of pirates would
have seen him they probably woulda damn
thrown harpoons in him you know he's big
too fat blubbery rubenesque they called
it at the time you know pretty happy man
though overall I remember that but I
know that if it was real bright out and
he had to be outdoors or if he was at a
picnic whatever that his cousin would
kind of throw a tarp over him to keep
the Sun off of him and I always thought
that that was pretty sentimental you
know when somebody and your family cared
enough to to cover you up with a tarp or
to you know hold something over your
head so that the Sun or the what the
elements didn't get you you know I wish
people in our neighborhood would have
done that with their cars and stuff a
lot of rust and uh I grew up really not
in the Rust Belt in the tetanus Belt
where you needed a shot if you were
planning on getting out and about end of
the world you know that but Jerry Lewis
died man you want to go back and watch
some of his uh some of his work I
watching an original Nutty Professor and
you can see at the time I mean Jerry
Lewis was they don't have artists like
they don't really allow you to function
at that level of confidence very rarely
like you'll see like a Neil Patrick
Harris can do that when he's hosting
like the Tony Awards or something where
he's he's singing he's dancing he's
telling jokes it's one to the next but
Jerry Lewis I was like that constantly
and I think directors and programming on
television used to allow the actors to
move and breathe it wasn't every shot
wasn't just so such a close-up and okay
this line and now this line in this line
in this line and the actors had chances
to be more whimsical even on late-night
shows the talent had chances I feel like
to be more whimsical and he was as
whimsical as they came Jerry Lewis I
mean you can watch him almost at any age
it was extremely impressive you know and
I just wished that talent these days had
that freedom you know these days it's
almost like the art caters we got to get
to get the episode moving so that it can
get to the commercial break so that you
know we'll keep the commercials happy
whereas if you look at older stuff and
older pictures it looked like it was
more just like that the whole whatever
the production was the show the film it
could breathe a little bit and maybe
that was just Jerry Lee Lewis re not
Jerry Lee Lewis Jerry Lewis maybe it was
just Jerry Lewis who they let him they
let him breathe because he had that they
could rely on him that much he had that
much talent but a very special man go
check him out what else happened this
weekend man I went to the beach went to
the beach out here in Santa Monica I
took a nap in the sunshine you ever done
that feels great when you start feels
insane when you wake up when you get
home part of your face part of your body
one you know half of your neck half of
your cheek and I was out there at Santa
Monica while I was at the beach by the
pier and I'll tell you this man you get
out in the water out there I went out
for a swim not the best idea
swimming by the pier I didn't know that
a lot of sewage runoff goes out there
right first of all so I kept thinking
this waters say
nd right there was sand in it for sure
who knows what else was in it man and
you're out there and that's a violin
ocean they call it the Pacific but I'll
tell you this
that's a bait and switch on you because
you get out there in that Pacific and
that thing is doing anything but acting
pacified all right I'll say that I was
right by the pier and I remember I got I
got pushed out a little you know I'm out
there kind of surviving because I don't
swim as much as I kind of survive in the
water that's more how I you know operate
in the in the ocean
not in pools and pools like me hadn't
kind of handle myself shallow in I'm a
master of the shallow when I'm damn I'm
Daniel day-lewis in the shallow end you
know my left foot my right foot I will
drink your milkshake
you know what I'm saying I'll do it all
in the shallow end I'm a [ __ ] you
know I'm damn you know
Tonya Harding you know damn gyah
Garibaldi or whoever somebody that can
dance you know
Gillian hoof but I'll you know I'll
handle over the shallow end but I get
into the deep end that's when things get
squirrely for me and in the ocean so I'm
out there I'm kind of starting to drift
a little bit it's getting violent the
water is getting violent you know and
there's a lot of alcoholics out there
and there's two fellows pissing off the
DA the doc because that Santa Monica
Pier is right there the one you've seen
all the movies with the ferris wheel and
kids are all geeked up and fired up so I
start drifting off in this area we're
not even allowed to swim in for some
reason I don't know why I mean I'm
guessing cuz the ocean can push you up
against the the the wooden parts of the
pier you know the things that are
holding you up though they're just like
big brown chopsticks I don't know what
they are other pieces of wood you know
what they are you know quit making me
describe them but yeah I got pushed in
these tutors are pissed and right off of
it alcoholics you know I'm guessing
alcoholics cuz everybody else is hanging
out with their children and tendon you
know to their kids and keeping son out
of each other's eyes and these men are
out there urinating you know firing off
things that they drink and previously
the day before today and dripping that
out of their wieners out into the water
and I'm getting spooked cuz I'm like
getting pushed in that general direction
right and then it gets closer and closer
and it's like you know sometimes the
ocean you
realize how powerful it is so I
literally have to like go underwater and
swim under this you know this urine that
these boys are doing and that that's one
of those moments to where you just
realize that you know that mother
nature's in control that life isn't
always gonna go how you want it you know
so that was kind of like if I don't see
the solar eclipse tomorrow having to
hold my breath and swim under water that
had other men's urine in it coming
straight down just I mean just straight
down you know I mean it was probably the
water I was hitting was probably at that
point for 4% urine but when you know
it's coming in hot like that it's it's
alarming but anyway swam under that that
was my eclipse you know swimming from
regular water and then having to swim
pass in front of two adult men doing
urine so but yeah the beach was fun man
you know I realized I don't mind I don't
mind the beach once I get there I'm good
you know half my face is really red
today part of my back's a little
squirrel DUP but I what I don't like is
getting to the beach parking I don't
like you know some guy comes by my
window some Frenchmen
he tells me I can have his parking spot
then he goes and gets in his car for I'm
not joking 12 minutes dude sits there
I'm waiting right other cars are passing
me getting other spots it's an extremely
small lot right there on Santa Monica
finally man I look over there dude I'll
go get a peep at the dude right dudes
rest and bro eyes closed resting in his
car the [ __ ] French man the [ __ ]
French you know French me once shame on
me you won't French me again I'm not
falling for this French [ __ ] so yeah so
that that you know Jerry Lee Lewis we
got the Eclipse
dealt with the French you I don't like
to sigh you know I don't like I don't
think that I'll really so much like
dealing with the French and then it God
has put a French taste in my mouth man
and I don't like it but what else
occurred man this weekend
not much you know China nuts is trying
to stuff them cigarettes you know and I
probably only had yesterday I think I
had three or four cigarettes probably
four because you know a lot of times
we'll say something and it's usually the
that's usually the amount that we don't
want to admit to so we'll try and cheat
it but I probably have four cigarettes
yesterday but man they just make me feel
squirreled up you know they make me feel
like I don't know they make me feel like
there's like there's just little mites
in my body that don't that aren't happy
that's what they make me feel that make
me feel like something's in me that's
unhappy and that's the drugs it's in
them they put drugs and cigarettes ah
what else that's kind of it man you know
I'm going to Vancouver next weekend but
not for comedy got my fantasy football
league coming up
I can't I'm so happy for fantasy
football man I remember last year when
feminism was at a crazy height you know
when there were you know where men were
disappearing a crawl off the streets and
showing back up months later in wigs and
you know no uh and that no just a dead
look in their eyes you know women were
ripping men off the streets and probably
castrating him in basements or doing
whatever they were doing you know and
football seasons showed up and it was
like the greatest thing that ever
happened just to have a little bit of
manhood loose in the world like
something it was it was something it was
okay to talk about when you were a man
you know just cuz I mean and I
understand you know you've got to have
some waves where you know you have to
have ebbs and flows of things but I
remember it got so it got so insane that
you felt like you couldn't even admit
you were a man in the morning you almost
had to be like hey you know happy to be
here I might be a woman I don't know
we'll see you know it's almost like it
alike you know pledged like that you
don't know it might be might be a woman
in a few years considering it just to
even walk around and that's here in Los
Angeles I'm talking about but let's get
to some dates man I got some calls
but yeah I'm gonna Vancouver's weak and
I'm excited about getting into Canada
you know it's just there in Montreal but
I'm excited about getting back I will be
at the cap city comedy club in Austin
and this September 7th 8th and 9th
I'll be at hilarities in Cleveland
September 14th through 17th and then
October I'll be out here in Los Angeles
November I'll be in Huntsville and that
isn't November 16th through the 19th
that's Huntsville Alabama so I'm stoked
about that you can check out tickets
everything at the ov on comm slash tour
I've want you to stand-up comedy bits
and I'm putting up and enjoy the Eclipse
you know I will say enjoy it even if you
go outside to peek on what it is I think
this is one thing that's gonna bring
people together even if it's just for a
minute I mean I think here in LA we can
only see it for a minute and a half and
we only get about 63 percent of the Sun
will be eclipsed I don't think it's
gonna be like nighttime but if it is
dude pull out some nighttime antics you
know what I'm saying
touch somebody's nuts dude live a little
bit touch your own nuts you know what am
i saying somebody else's that could be
illegal if you don't know these people
touch your own nuts dude you know what
I'm saying it's sneaky and in your pants
do something squirrely break a rule you
can't break a rule anymore break a rule
you know I'm saying a scratch yes a
little you know call somebody a
[ __ ] you know walk outside with
somebody from your company that you
don't know stare at the Sun you don't
need glasses if your boss lets you out
to watch the Eclipse and they don't
require you to have glasses or give you
glasses we're talking about one of the
potential greatest class-action lawsuits
of all time look we live in a lawsuit
universe I hate to say it I don't like
it but that's what it is all right so
get out there if your boss says it's
okay get your eyes open tape your eyes
open you know what I'm saying
get that money get that eclipse cash
stacks on stacks on stacks solar stacks
lunar stacks stack a deck Alice boy you
know I'm a straight-up
stack asaurus Rick's get that money
alright so let's get into some calls I
appreciate all the love and support you
can hit the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three talk about
anything something you heard today the
the new studio is still coming along you
know I got my assistant on Monday my boy
Ken and he's a producer till we do some
projects together comes over starts
building the studio leaves leaves his
tools everything like okay did he did
you get kidnapped he got kidnapped you
gone what happened so couldn't even
really navigate it but gonna try to this
week you know gonna try to finish it up
but we're coming along the dining room
is turned into a studio so I'm excited
thank you guys for your support listener
ships increase and I'm excited about
that
hit the hotline let's talk about some
things let me know how you feel you know
do you feel like a war or a a natural
disaster would help humanity
I know it's extreme I know it's an
extreme thought but let's think about it
and also if you hear me talk about
something on this podcast and you don't
like it got a lot of emails last week
right a lot of emails it's fine if you
don't like it you know I'm I probably
wouldn't everything that you shared but
call me and let me know why you don't
like it I'm okay with learning a new
perspective I'm okay with not being
right you know I'm not here to be right
you know but I am here to be able to
share how I feel you know I am here I
mean I'm a here you all day I'm beaten
feel flakes baby I open up a big bag of
feel flakes cuz you're gonna know how I
feel but I don't have to be right I'm
okay with being wrong you know if you
want to help me be if you want to help
show me that I'm wrong I'm perfectly
fine with that hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three let's get into a call or to heal
one of the things we asked was how you
felt about if the world were ending what
were your thoughts B what would you do
with your time what would happen last
day let's check in with some
some of that would appeal um there's an
adage a calling from the Northwest area
okay we got JJ from the Northwest area
all right thank you for calling it I
hope you're okay
you sound you sound a little bit like
something you're hurt or some hope
you're not hurt you know my buddy uh and
I don't know where the Northwest area
sounds super vague but we're gonna keep
listening god bless you this time what
would you do if the world is coming to
end as you know it yet one day left
honestly bro what I would do is I would
just want to be around all my family you
know I don't know where crazy or do
anything crazy I think you know made
some big barbecue with all your family
know well big barbecue with all your
family that'd be interesting I
appreciate you calling brother yeah big
barbecue would be interesting but then
you're gonna have to invite everybody
over for this are they all gonna you
know I guess I should have just let you
know we should have decided on how long
in advance he knew the world was ending
but let's say yeah you got the end of
the world barbecue Wow it'd be pretty
cool what kind of music would you play
you know you'd probably have to drop a
little bit of Tupac in there
I'd go with some probably some I want to
say Kenny Chesney but I'd even go with
some some you know you need some
heartfelt americana country in there too
I think I would go with maybe some not
Travis Tritt Who am I thinking of maybe
[ __ ] I might throw some Shania in there
you know turn that thing up get the
ladies pumping a little bit
you know I'd throw a little cupid
shuffle in there because it's family so
you wanna you you know you're gonna have
grandma out there hitting that that uh
that cupid shuffle you know that love
movement that's beautiful man I love
watching an old woman danced there's
something beautiful about it watching a
baby and an old woman dance there's
something beautiful about it isn't there
you know I remember ice two-step at
night on the internet looking at videos
of seniors dance and
people and community college a lot I
used to watch a lot of community college
beauty contests on YouTube and there's
some really good ones on there you think
it's wild but there are some good ones
and but the videos that would get me the
most would be senior citizens dancing
with children there's something special
about it
you know something bringing us all
together but yeah barbecue but then you
got like what if the food is bad what if
you got the shitty potato salad you
sound like you're taking along a lot of
responsibility you know and I'm gonna
judge a little bit by how you sound here
I don't if you're stoned
but you sound you know if you call into
the hotline stand up or sit up when you
call and talk you know this is a
conversation you know just respect it a
little bit in that sense unless you have
are on a machine or something brother
and if that's the case then you know God
be good to you and I hope that if you
need a lung or something hit me up you
know cuz I think I I don't know I don't
have good lungs I got a small esophagus
you know I got the heart of a lesbian
and I got the esophagus of a cat that
they told me when I was young when I
first went to the doctor he said you
have the SD uh you got the windpipe of
one of the large of a very large cat the
man said
they're an ox nor Hospital in New
Orleans mr. Bob Aaron's Minh told me
that then I had the windpipe of a large
large cat but uh yeah I like an idea
barbeque but then you think of wouldn't
that potato salad you know people are
gonna get scared then towards the end of
the barbecue I think the first two hours
are gonna be a hit you know you're
probably gonna want to have liquor on
hand people or definitely want to drink
on the way out how does it end though
when you really think about it think
about it you're at the family barbecue
the world's ending the sun's going down
to your last sunset what happens in do
people get territorial people get sad is
the whole family huddled up is it what
about that pervy uncle is he reaching
around the huddle you know is he trying
to you know is he trying to touch a
young ass cheek of somebody that's a
distant cousin you know first cousin is
illegal second cousin not illegal you
can look it up you say it's creepy or
whatever yes
creepy right it's creepy out here when I
got a million days to live but when
you're on that last day how creepy is
that if you have I'm not talking fully
sexual but I'm talking if you wanted to
kiss you know kiss somebody and just see
what the feeling was like one last time
you know you know around 11 o'clock
people be jumping over into the
neighbor's yard probably looking for sex
do you think that or do you think you'd
all just sit there and and be harmonious
you know it's really interesting if
you're rich and you can judge me and say
well Theo this is grotesque to think
about that's fine that's fine if it's it
is a little bit grotesque but to think
about it isn't you know to think about
you're right there you know people are
that's the end of the day it's the party
that some things have gone okay the
potato salad was rancid somebody's sick
it's the end of the world some of the
kids went to bed early
what the [ __ ] you know nine-year-old
Lawrence he fell asleep early what they
don't even care so maybe maybe one of
your somebody got too [ __ ] up passed
out there missing the end but you know
you can have somebody as deviant in the
family they're gonna want to jump across
and maybe be swingers and do something
reach out to the neighbors I'm just
saying I appreciate your call man it's
interesting to think about what it would
really be like at the end of the world
you know what it would really really
really uh really be like I don't know
let's take another call here we go hey
Jew boy Tom from rural North Carolina
just calling for word basically if the
world were to end today and we knew it
how would I handle that all right this
is Tom from rural North Carolina Tom's
called before he's a frequent caller now
and Tom I like the way that you call man
and that's one of the reasons you know I
know I'm a little bit testy tonight guys
but you know I'm trying not to have a
damn cigarette dude you know I mean I
did it I would suck a tobacco farmers
kick right now just to see you know just
to maybe catch a drag at some simple
going through that moment I know it'll
only last about 30 seconds but that's
what happens you know it's what happens
sometimes
and I'm not even a regular so I can't
even imagine what this is like for
severe smokers I cannot even imagine Wow
but if you also if you smoke and like it
go go enjoy a cigarette I'm not trying
to rain on anybody's parade but thank
you for calling Tom from rural North
Carolina that's tobacco country I can
smell it through the through the
speakers here but thank you for calling
about the topic what would you do Tom
it's the end of the world it's your last
day let's hear it so what I would do is
I just I'll go to work the other day go
home girl wait you go to work dude
that's a company man bro you would go to
work
Tom we're talking about the end of the
world you're gonna go spend seven you're
gonna be the only person at FedEx who's
bringing their [ __ ] in eat overnight is
the best service there's no overnight
nobody's coming in Tom nobody's coming
in and get the radio fixed or to you
know or to you know buy some new
software something I don't even know
where you work you know nobody's coming
in to me I mean maybe if you ran like a
horse place somebody would come in to
get to get a couple of horses you know
because it's the last day of their lives
and they've never done horseback riding
or if you ran like a roller skating
thing you know people want to probably
come in maybe spend a little bit of time
in the rink but time you're talking
about going to work I don't know where
you work at it's fascinating that you're
a lifeguard you're the only [ __ ] two
there but you're a company man you're an
organized man you stick with the
schedule that's interesting Tom I never
thought about that I think most people
would call in there would be the one day
they would be able to call their boss
and be like I'm never fit everybody
would quit they would have to be the
first thing you would do in the morning
wake up quit work I think by by 1:00
p.m. I think half of the half of the
half of the world would be naked right
there what by 1:00 p.m. I remember an
experience I had I went on this thing
called semester at sea and it's like a
floating University and you're gonna it
was a gift so
gifted this to me I would not have been
able to to have this experience on my
own regard just financially it was
interesting but I remember so you go
around the world on this cruise ship and
you're at sea for 100 days it's a
floating University right it's a
floating University and you get to the
and you the further you get along I
noticed people started losing clothes
you know by about day 60 you could go to
class without a shirt and the women
would wear bikini tops and by day 90 I
remember being in class in a speedo and
it was totally okay
it wasn't just like there were a couple
of kids that would do it and the rest of
the boys if they felt you know just
comfortable enough they would have no
shirt on and people had wild hairdos and
you just start to develop you start to
get freer and freer that's what I
noticed over time we got freer and freer
and I think if it's the end of the world
that you're gonna have that whole
experience kind of you know just
expedited in a day or in the days
leading up to it and but I think by 1
p.m. that last day that most of the
world would be probably naked just to
have that feeling of what does this feel
like you know have I been caged up in my
clothes you know what kind of existence
have I been living that I was kind of
forced to live into just by the by the
the bumper lanes that were put on the
society around me I don't know just
interesting thought but I do remember on
that on that cruise by the last 10 days
we were in class you know just out in
some ocean somewhere and we were in
speedos and it was totally ok everybody
was comfortable with it it was really
interesting just how we got almost you
know just got back to being comfortable
in our skin all right onward I'm sorry
Tom on with the rest of your call now
that your day at work is over what would
you do you know what makes me happy
every day lift away to makes me happy
being with her makes me happy just
trying to be as happy as possible or the
last moments we have and I would
definitely a sappy sentimental of the
sounds I definitely just sit there and
I'd hold her hand as we die
Wow let me think about that
so Tom said he would spend he would go
to work he would go to the gym that's
pretty dope actually that's pronunce
commitment I like that that part I
definitely get you know going to the gym
I just get my life I'm going I am taking
my spirit to the end of the line and
sticking to my commitments I like that
and then you'd sit there with your girl
and you would hold her hand uh I think
that's sweet man you know I think you
would have people like outside of the DV
and uncles and the swingers and the
people who you know put more of their
balls into the sexual court I think
you'd have a lot of people who are we're
lovers you seem like a lover Tom who
would probably do that too you know who
maybe just sit there with their whole
family and hold hands
you know maybe play a game or just go
around in a circle and tell stories
about how you really felt about each
other because you'd have to get
everything off your chest you know you'd
have to you know you'd have to get rid
of all the the pain and the hurt and a
you know and all the love and the
affection and the hope and the you'd
have to get it all out I mean I bet a
lot of people be calling people like
around 11:00 a.m. that they always were
in love with and afraid to tell them
you'd have a lot of crazy stuff a lot of
phone lines would be down a lot of crazy
memes a young kid the Millennials would
all just be doing memes the youngest
though young young Millennials I mean
you know like 11 years old they would
all just be sending dirt memes to each
other not knowing what to do but that's
interesting it's interesting you'd sit
there because there's something very
manly about that even though you say
that that's sappy there's something
manly about you know that you're gonna
be there with with this lady that you
love and not let her go into oblivion
alone or at least not let her think that
she is you know and I think there's
something uh there's something still
chivalry's not dead even though the
world is huh even though the world would
be this is all hypothetical guys and I
think we're keeping it pretty
light-hearted so this is good you know I
think he's you need thoughts all right
let's move onward we get another call
this one came in
from Canada our neighbors to the north
hey yo Jim here hey Jim callin from
Canada cause more serious issue here I
think my dog been sexually abused what
happened with her let someone look after
them and when I got him back he was
acting funny he wouldn't eat his food no
more okay so this is you know this is an
interesting call this is Jim and he
believes that his dog may have been
sexually abused may have been this isn't
a stunt call I just want to let you guys
know that all these calls are are real
on word he's not even eating his food
anymore I can't tell this is a joke or
not let's go one word didn't want anyone
to touch them and um saying is the
person who was looking after him is uh
I've known them to be a sexual deviant
in the past so what should i do should I
call the police
like where do I go from here because uh
I don't want my dog being like
emotionally scarred from this what do
you recommend I do thanks
I mean if you call the police I don't
know you know honestly I don't know I
don't have any suggestions I've never
owned a dog I got attacked by a bunch of
dogs twice my birthday growing up
another time I got attacked by some cats
I got attacked by a lot of animals so I
never had a dog you know I didn't know
you could pet a dog until I was probably
about 11 years old I didn't know that
people had him as pets and kept him in
their homes so what do you do it mean it
I don't know if I would let someone
watch my dog if I believe that they have
I mean how deviant is this purse I mean
if you think they're that deviant I
think you need to think before lending
them anything you know I don't even
think I'd lend that guy out were
screwdriver you know he'd probably try
to hide it hide it hide it in his butt
so you know letting him watch a dog that
you love or whatever and that's crazy to
me and I'm sorry that you I guess I'm
sorry you did that you
I mean dogs are resilient animals you
know I'd read about this or call our SPS
or uh call a veterinarian you know I
think I'm the wrong I'm the wrong person
to call for this man you know but best
of luck to you okay let's take another
another cut another call here thank you
very much for hitting the hotline again
the hotline number is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three high
heels
my name is Connie Rosario love the
podcast just want to ask how do you deal
with like feeling trapped okay this is
Miss Joyce REO and she's asking how do
you feel with how do you deal with
feeling trapped like to be in anything
my work just been feeling trapped lately
just okay she's been feeling trapped
lately I know her calls kind of low she
said Theo how do you deal with feeling
trapped you know by life work wanted to
know if you had any advice for that what
do you know if I had any advice for that
thank you for calling young lady our
female listeners ship has been growing
so that's been exciting and I appreciate
the call well I'll just I'll say this
because you said how do you deal with
feeling trapped and I want to say that
you know that's a it's a feeling you
know you're feeling trapped and is that
the actuality you know because I'm
starting to learn in my life that my
feelings aren't reality you know my
feelings and sometimes even my feelings
are you know they're they usually will
tell me that I don't feel good but the
reality is that that's not the case you
know the reality is that things are
better than they feel you know the
reality is that if I suffer from
depression that sometimes my feelings
will just feel bad even if the even if
my life is not that way so if you're
feeling trapped is that the reality at
first I would just look at that you know
and this is just a suggestion based on
you know some of them
my experiences you know I would just
look at the reality you know because
because your actions are gonna be what's
real you know if you're going to work
and you have people around you that care
about you and you're taking care of
yourself and you know all of these
things then those actions sound really
good those actions sound promising and
those actions sound like you're doing a
good job of living for you or for anyone
but if you're but if you're feeling
trapped it could just be the feeling and
sometimes what helps get rid of bad
feelings is just by noticing the actions
that you're taking you know it sounds
like you're going to work I don't know
what's going on in your life but you
know if it's good things then then the
trap discussed be a feeling with that
said if I felt trapped before yeah I
feel trapped sometimes by like when it
comes to dating and stuff like that I
feel really trapped when it comes to
relationships and I don't know why you
know I don't know why really I'm
actually seeing a therapist now I'll see
her today actually right after the clips
I walk into her office and she is like a
sex and love sort of therapist but
basically she just helps you think she's
a regular therapist but she kind of
specifies in those sorts of worlds and
she can help you think about why you
behave or feel the way you do in certain
relationships so maybe if you're really
feeling bad you know maybe see a
therapist if you think that that could
help what else you're feeling trapped
you know by life you could always try
changing some things up and you could
also always try just like a lot of times
I remember for years I would wake up and
think man I know what my life's gonna be
like today it's am I gotta go to work I
got to do this I got and then I have to
come home and then I have to go to the
gym or then I got to go get groceries
and then I gotta remember to you know
empty the DVR or whatever and but before
I even walked out of the front door I'd
already lived my entire day in my head
and I'd already decided that it was
mundane and that it was repetitive and
then it wasn't gonna be enjoy
and so then that's how my day went and
all day I just felt trapped in this and
this day that I already knew how it was
gonna go and things never changed for me
because I didn't allow them room to
change I know that sounds bizarre but in
my mind I didn't whereas if I would have
got up in the morning and said hey today
I get to go to work today
then I get to come home and I get to go
to the gym or I get to hug my you know
kid or bird or whatever you have or you
know you know or I get to meet the
exterminator he's coming to get the
spiders you know I get to do these
things I get to live I get to eat lunch
um instead of man I got to eat lunch
again at the same place across the
street no man I get to eat lunch today
holy [ __ ] almost make yourself ignorant
in a way so that everything can be a
surprise in a way it's just really about
possibility because then if you walk out
of the door and say wow I get to go to
work it just feels different and then I
get to go to the gym Wow anything could
happen at the gym instead of thinking
man at the gym I'm gonna have to do this
weights and this weights in this weights
it's already ruined your workout it's
not exciting but if you go to the gym
like man I could do anything I want I
get to do whatever even if you're just
gonna do the same [ __ ] you always do at
the gym the way you approach it
if you leave possibility there you know
anything could happen at the gym you
know I might win a new shirt if there's
a raffle or um but somebody might buy me
a milkshake or I might get a milkshake
after who knows anything is possible you
know I might fall in love I might
somebody might jerk me off somewhere
behind a machine you know I might jerk
off behind a machine I mean those are
crazy ideas but if you leave possibility
then you're walking around with
possibility the world suddenly that
you've lived in a million days in a row
suddenly it's full of mystery and
intrigue and possibility but those are
some thoughts that I have but if you're
really feeling trapped honey or I don't
mean honey because that's sometimes
belittling me even though I don't think
it's belittling I think it just means
like sweet girl
you know sweet young lady if you're
really feeling trapped you know and it
continues to feel it could be some
psychological stuff I don't know so you
might want to maybe talk to a therapist
about it but if not those are just some
things that I do sometimes that help me
when I'm not feeling good you know and
just keep talking to people you know
just don't uh you don't feel trapped by
yourself you know just don't feel
trapped by yourself and you're not now
since you told me now we're trapped well
we're in avalanche you know what's gonna
happen in here you know who's gonna be
the first one to fart in the avalanche
you know stupid things but when you open
it up to possibility even if it's
ridiculous it makes it better than me
like [ __ ] dang we're stuck in an
avalanche is gonna suck you know we'll
probably be dead in 17 days you know one
of us will have to eat the other one you
know boo so I think just keep some
possibility maybe that can help you feel
better
but I do hope that you feel better and I
appreciate you calling I appreciate
everybody calling I appreciate the calls
continue to hit the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three I
have to leave actually I got to go do a
set at the Comedy Store the world-famous
Comedy Store I'll be in Vancouver this
weekend coming up if you know anything
fun there to do let me know I do a
destination fantasy football draft every
year and this year we're gonna go to
Vancouver so I'm very excited about that
you can hit the store Theo von comm
slash store to get both of my albums
that are out to grab a t-shirt or also
we have these beautiful prints that are
right behind me you can see them on the
YouTube and they say keeping my squad
hydrated and they are that's a line from
one of the album's I want to thank sure
my editor I want to thank Ken the
videographer and that's it man that's it
and I want to thank you guys for
listening to me this week and for
joining me and and if you have ideas of
things you want to talk about it when
you you want to hear about our
discussions you want to start hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and let's talk
about things together man listen I want
to talk about what you want to talk
about you know I don't want this to be
just about my idea
I want to know some of yours and and I'm
grateful and um yeah huh you guys helped
me get through that craving for a
cigarette
Wow thank you that really helped me I
don't feel it anymore so I'm gonna
celebrate living man you know that's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna celebrate
living
I hope you have a good Eclipse huh
you're gonna see it will it be cool what
if it's a dud I don't think it will be
dude it could be what if it eclipses and
then an aliens show up what if aliens
show up dude and what if honestly all
they want to do suck people's qex bro
Wow imagine spending you know the next
couple months playing hide our [ __ ]
from aliens and women the women will be
pissed because the aliens won't be
interested in them you know they'll
probably blame it on us some of them you
know some of the ones who write articles
you know they'd be like these guys are
hugging all the aliens
we're not hogging them okay you're
trying to suck our dicks lady you know
cut us some slack we didn't tell them to
come here and do it they're doing it you
can't be left out because just because
aliens aren't interested in you right
now you know gosh can't we have anything
can we have aliens can't poor white
people have aliens you know that'd be
the coolest of aliens only wanted to
blow poor white dudes you know because
even though people say oh dang bummer
people would feel left out if aliens
weren't chasing them they would 100%
it's just how we're built celebrate
living man I'd be naked by 1:00 p.m.
probably jumping over the neighbors
fence but then I'd come back and hold
hands and do the powwow I think that's
what I would do but be good to
yourselves man take care of yourselves
be good to yourselves you know I bet you
deserve it I'll see you guys next week
thank you